a veces son puntos con lineales y de
esta entre a y c la proporción de ave el
segmento lo que mide el segmento ave
respecto al segmento hace es 2 a 5 nos
dice si ya se encuentra en 6 como en
menos 69 y ve en menos 23 muy bien nos
preguntan cuáles son las coordenadas de
ce muy bien entonces ahí está el
problema te invito a que como siempre
hagas una pausa lo intentes por ti mismo
y después comparamos nuestros resultados
entonces vamos a tratar de hacerlo
geométricamente digamos nos dice que a
veces son co lineales y que b está entre
a y c entonces digamos que aquí anda el
punto
digamos este es a igual a menos 6,9
ahí está el a ibex se encuentra pues más
o menos cerca no sé vamos a ponerlo por
ejemplo aquí este es el punto b igual a
al menos 23 como nos lo indican ahora
nos dice que los tres puntos están en la
misma línea entonces vamos a tratar de
hacerlo ahí tienen el primer pedazo de
línea y luego esta línea sigue ok vamos
a tratar de hacer un mejor esfuerzo
ahí lo tienen esta línea sigue
hasta no sé hasta el punto ce digamos
que ahí esté el punto c la idea es que
se vea como que son la misma línea muy
bien entonces ahí lo tienen se no
sabemos qué coordenadas tiene ese es el
problema no sabemos qué coordenadas
tiene y hay que obtenerlas lo único que
sabemos es que la proporción de ave con
respecto a hace es 2 a 5 muy bien
entonces lo que podemos hacer es tomar
la las coordenadas digamos la distancia
vamos a llamarlo la distancia horizontal
de ave que digamos de ave tiene una
distancia horizontal y ésta está en
proporción 2 a 5 con respecto a toda
ésta con respecto a toda esta muy bien
entonces cuál es el cambio que hubo de
menos 6 a menos 2 pues hubo un
incremento de 4 verdad si a esta
distancia digamos la distancia
horizontal de hace le llamamos x
lo que sabemos es que la proporción
entre 4 y x es justamente 2 a 5 muy bien
muy bien entonces vamos a ver cómo
resolvemos esto pues tomamos por ejemplo
recíprocos o inversos multiplicativos y
tenemos que x entre 4 es cinco medios si
multiplicamos por cuatro de ambos lados
por cuatro tendremos que x es igual a 5
por 420 entre 2 son 10 muy bien entonces
la respuesta o bueno más bien el cambio
que hay de hace en la dirección
horizontal son diez pero nosotros
empezamos en menos seis así que si le
sumamos diez tendremos un cuatro y
tenemos nuestra primera coordenada que
es la coordenada en la dirección x vamos
a ver qué pasa con la dirección vertical
entonces aquí tenemos
a esta altura aunque íbamos de 9 a 3
entonces tuvimos un buen o no
incrementamos verdad en realidad fue un
este bajamos 6 unidades de 9 a 3
ok fue una cantidad decreciente ahora
esto vamos a compararlo con esta altura
completa que es vamos a llamarle jay que
es lo que no conocemos muy bien entonces
ahora lo que sabemos es que menos 6 está
en proporción con respecto a y lo mismo
que dos quintos por por las condiciones
que nos dieron en el problema y mismo
truco podemos tomar el recíproco o el
inverso multiplicativo y esto nos queda
entre menos seis es 5 sobre 2 muy bien
si multiplicamos por menos 6 de ambos
lados por menos 6 tendremos que esto se
cancelan y nos queda que es igual a 5 x
menos 6 son menos 30 y entre 2 son menos
entonces en realidad bajamos 15 unidades
pero empezamos en 9 verdad y si quitamos
15 tendremos aquí menos 6 muy bien
entonces como lo obtuvimos simplemente
descomponemos el problema en las
coordenadas verticales las coordenadas
horizontales y esta proporción se
preserva también con respecto a esas dos
direcciones con eso podemos obtener las
coordenadas de ce que es 4,26 y ahí lo
tienen esa es la respuesta